People change their e-mail addresses for lots of reasons.
Some decide they need a more professional sounding address.
Others change their name when they get married and want a new address to match.
Others just want to switch e-mail services altogether.
To change your e-mail address, first sign up for a new one.
Fill out the online form, make sure everything is correct,...
...and then click "I accept, create my account."
Then, e-mail your contacts from this new account to let them know you changed addresses.
Some Webmail services, including Gmail, let you forward mail from one account to another.
To do this, sign in to your old account, visit the Forwarding section of Settings,...
...and set up your old account to forward mail to your new one.
That way, you won't miss anything as you make the switch.